you're probably wondering what the fresh
hell this is what makes spiders think
they're welcome in the oceans now good
news
spiders still aren't welcome in the
ocean this year sea spider is a
different kind of critter entirely a
super special kind of arthropod you'll
find them pretty much everywhere in the
ocean from the shallows to the depths
the shallow species tend to be more
extravagant like this one after all
survival on a reef is about blending in
but down deeper flamboyance ain't any
use at over a mile deep no light
penetrates safer when a submersible
shined a flashlight in your face down
here sea spiders tend to be lankier
that's because of the deep soft silt by
having longer legs a sea spider can
avoid sinking up to its neck in the muck
alright maybe the sea spider doesn't
have a neck in fact the rest of its body
is miniscule compared to its legs it's
so tiny that the sea spiders guts
overflow into its legs and why yes I'm
glad you asked its genitals are there
too anyway the sea spider isn't exactly
the quickest or least conspicuous hunter
so it tends to pick on organisms that
can't move sponges and corals for
instance though something sluggish like
a worm is fair game to sea spiders just
gotta mind those currents whoops
whoops